♪♪
-Hey, everybody.
I'm going to try to keep things
moving a little bit faster
because our last two
have been over 20 minutes,
which the last thing we want
is for our average of these
to go for 20 minutes or we are
no longer Emmy-eligible.
So if I'm talking
a little bit faster, that's why.
[ Laughter ]
Two weeks ago,
I said in "A Closer Look"
you can microwave your testicles
and was told you can't
because it doesn't work
with the door open.
So I had to,
last week in "Corrections,"
let everybody down,
say that wasn't possible.
Then a few -- I guess you would
call them life hackers
said if you
break off the little...
plastic door catches
and you put them in,
it'll trick the microwave
into thinking it's closed,
so you'll be good to go.
The dream's alive.
[ Laughter ]
I did an impression...
in yesterday's "Closer Look"
of Darth Vader saying,
"Soon the universe
will bow to the Empire."
The Empire was not trying
to rule the whole universe,
just the one galaxy.
So...
apologies for making them...
I guess, like,
seem power hungry.
[ Laughter ]
In my defense,
it's not like they mentioned
or stress the...
galaxy part in "Star Wars."
Whoa, what's that?
Right away?
[ Laughter ]
Like seventh word?
So, I said yesterday that...
I've been traveling by Zorb.
But then we showed
this picture right here,
and I was told
this is not a Zorb.
This is --
This is just a water ball.
A Zorb has
two layers of plastic.
And this one burns
because we were this close
to getting Zorb as a sponsor.
[ Laughter ]
This has been "A Closer Look."
Politics got you down?
Wish you could roll down a hill
in a giant plastic ball?
Try Zorb.
Hey, this is a correction
for you guys.
Catch up on "Severance."
It's our jam. We're going
to talk about it a lot.
You won't regret it.
Great first season.
Perfect finale.
So, pterodactyls.
I keep calling them dinosaurs.
They're not dinosaurs.
They're pterosaurs.
But kindly...
many jackals have said,
"This isn't on you.
This is on the dinosaur toy
industrial complex,
which has long sort of
thrown pterodactyls in the mix."
Museum gift shops,
also to blame.
And so kids are growing up
thinking pterodactyls
are dinosaurs
when they're not.
And that obviously was something
that I want to set out to fix,
so I have taken it
upon myself.
I've been going to parks,
playgrounds.
You know, if I see
a group of kids,
I walk over
and I tell them,
"You're being lied to about
pterodactyls being dinosaurs."
And the upshot of this is,
one, kids aren't listening,
and, two, I'm...
I'm not allowed to go
in the park anymore.
[ Laughter ]
Few weeks back,
a lifeguard reached out
to talk about the proper way
to put on rubber gloves quickly.
Then I said, "Hey, if I'm
ever -- if I ever need CPR,
don't feel like you
got to put on gloves,
you know, for me."
Shame on me.
They put on gloves for them.
The lifeguard, you know,
because, you know,
they don't want to catch dis--
They don't want to do CPR
on someone who might have
something they could catch,
which that makes perfect sense.
I was, you know --
I was being selfish.
Just because you can't swim,
doesn't mean you also...
can't have hepatitis.
Last week's "Correction"
dropped on Earth Day,
and...
a number of you said, "Hey,
you were drinking water
out of a tiny plastic bottle
and if there's anything
we can do to help the Earth,
it is to, you know --
you got mugs on your desk.
Don't use -- We got to use
less plastic."
I totally agree.
I'm very excited to say
that I will be now --
From now on,
I will be drinking out of this.
And I think that's good
for the Earth.
[ Sighs ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Whispering ] I'm so sorry.
This is the last time.
[ Laughter ]
Mmm.
I was told my Vin Diesel
sounds like Sylvester Stallone.
That might be a note
for Vin Diesel.
[ Laughter ]
I did a Michael Caine
impression.
Not all of you were --
I'd say the reviews were mixed.
But, you guys,
let's not forget...
I played Michael Caine on "SNL."
Yeah.
Pretty -- Pretty big for me.
I don't -- Very hurtful
how much they're splashing
that "vintage" on there.
[ Laughter ]
Now, you might be thinking,
"God, I'm surprised Bill Hader
didn't
get to play Michael Caine."
He wasn't there yet.
There were still some crumbs
for the rest of us.
This is -- This is some
pretty interesting history.
Shoemaker, you remember this.
You remember
what this aired after?
This aired right after
Ashlee Simpson
got caught lip synching,
which is why it wasn't...
the buzziest thing
come Sunday.
The great Jude Law.
Jude Law was in my sketch,
that is the -- I don't know
what you call it.
Is it the the Holy Grail
of "Second Chance Theatres"?
This would be my favorite one
if we could ever do it.
"Hair Heads."
There's Jude Law.
There's Fred Armisen.
There's two actors who will not
be named playing Hair Heads.
Bobby Moynihan.
Wally, you were there
for "Hair Heads."
-Yeah.
-Do you remember how it played?
To silence. To exactly that.
[ Laughter ]
You guys all did
a great impression
of the audience
for "Hair Heads."
Mentioned Goofy this week.
Referred to Goofy as a dog...
...and a bunch of you said
he was a cow.
Now, thankfully,
some saner jackals stepped in
and pointed everyone
to a Snopes article
that debunked this claim.
I guess the cow rumor started
because Goofy
at one point dated
Clarabelle, the cow.
But people pointed out
that Clarabelle the cow,
also dated Horace Horsecollar,
the horse.
So there are two things
to take away from this.
It is Goofy is indeed a dog,
and Clarabelle
does not have a type.
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of goofy
love stories,
I said that Rudy Giuliani's
first wife
was his second cousin.
That was an incorrect statement.
It is an incorrect statement
to say
that Rudy Giuliani's first wife
was his second cousin,
because she still is
his second cousin.
[ Laughter ]
And that's the great thing
about...
marrying a cousin.
Because even after a divorce,
you still,
you know,
you still have that connection.
[ Laughter ]
They can't take it away.
[ Whispering ] I don't know
why they're smaller now.
This is even worse.
[ Laughter ]
[ Clears throat ]
[ Bottle clatters in distance ]
Called Andy Samberg last week
to ask him
if he would be interested
in taking Nic Cage's advice
and hosting "SNL" as Nic Cage.
He did not answer.
I said he wasn't home,
and then a bunch of you said,
"Well, you called him
on a landline."
It's just a way to say
that he didn't answer.
So I do want to call him.
The other thing is he texted.
He had time to text and said,
"Tell them I got 'The New York
Times' spelling bee.
I got Queen Bee,"
which is when you get everything
in "The New York Times" --
A lot of doubters out there
that don't believe
that Andy would get them all.
So, you know, again,
this is like --
I think less than 50/50 chance
that he'll answer, but...
[ Cellphone beeps ]
Unavailable.
That's just how it goes, guys.
But it's good for us
keeping it under 20.
[ Clicks tongue ]
I talked about how Sean Bean
dies in most of his movies.
Somebody said it's closer
to a third
or a quarter of his movies.
But we are talking about
Sean Bean death scenes,
and someone -- a jackal wrote
something that made me
laugh out loud when I read it
because it was so succinct
and to the point.
They wrote, "I would love to
watch a Mr. Bean death scene."
[ Laughter ]
We made a joke implying
that wrestling was fake.
We should have been clear.
The stories are scripted.
The stunts are real.
So, when a wrestler in the ring
gets hit with a chair,
they are, of course,
at risk of injury.
I should not have made light of
that, especially since if I --
if I were to be hit
by a chair, I would die.
Oh, mug.
We were talking
about how the mug is coming
and how I went down
to the merch people at NBC,
because sometimes
it's a little slow.
I was like, "Guys,
we really need this jackal mug
as quickly as possible."
And they said, "Okay,
but if we rush it,
we might get something wrong."
And I'm like, "How hard
could it be? It's a mug."
And they're like,
"Okay, we're just telling you."
And I'm like,
"Look, we just really need it.
The jackals have been so loyal.
Let's get them their mugs."
And then they sent me
a prototype.
And this...
This is what we got.
[ Laughter ]
I was like,
"How could you get that wrong?"
And they were like, "We told --
We told..."
And I was like,
"How do you even pick it up?"
Because if it's hot...
Anyway,
it's going to be a while.
This -- Somebody did the math.
If you add up all the
"Corrections" so far,
10 hours, 17 minutes.
"Lord of the Rings" --
9 hours, 17 minutes.
Extended version
"Lord of the Rings" --
11 hours, 22 minutes.
Which is amazing.
There's an extended version...
...of "Lord of the Rings"
for -- for who?
[ Chuckles ]
Oh, you got-- Oh,
there's an extended
march of the Ents.
Do you like
slow-moving tree people?
They really --
They really take their time
pushing through the brush.
Book update!
You guys,
I talked about my book,
"I'm Not Scared, You're Scared."
There we go.
And we had this helpful thing
that was sent to us
by "The New York Times,"
Week One, we were three.
Then we were four,
then we were six,
and then we were eight,
and we were nine.
However, you might remember last
week during "Corrections"
I said, "Hey guys,
a lot of Easter books up there.
Easter is over.
I think we got a chance
to stick around and..."
Hold on one sec.
This is the big reveal.
That's right. Sev--
We bounced up.
Post-Easter bounce up to seven.
My colleague Jimmy Fallon's
book right here,
"Nana Loves You More,"
also got the bounce
back up to two.
So I do hope I catch him.
And you will know
that I have caught Jimmy
on "The New York Times'"
bestseller list...
when I don't mention it.
[ Laughter ]
Respect the lead in.
Um...
Up.
We were talking about
grammar in Eminem songs,
and I warned jackals
not to criticize Eminem.
And...
...I said, "What's next?
You're going to say,
'Will the please -- you know,
will the real Slim Shady
please stand up?'
What? Ending your sentences
with prepositions much?"
And...
Turns up, I got it wrong.
"Up" in that case is an adverb.
It's not a preposition.
And that was...
[ Laughter ]
[ Clattering ]
And it's really exciting.
I got a letter.
The person -- One of the people
who responded was...
Well...This is new.
You can tell this is a new
letter that I just received
because no --
there's no fire damage.
Okay. So, there it says to me,
and it says, "All these jackals
are jerks to be fanatical
so let 'em know my lyrics
are perfectly grammatical.
And you, you're the one
that got the adverb wrong,
and I'm the one who found a curb
to stomp you on.
Oh [bleep],
that "on" was a preposition,
but let me address this mess in
a lesson if you'll listen.
Wherever I put a word
is where it's gonna go.
[Bleep] Strunk, [bleep] White.
That's all you gotta know."
And then it's signed.
You see where it's sighed?
"Eminem. Be white."
Pretty cool.